foreign
the first season of Silo came to an end
with a finale that found the perfect
balance between answering questions and
leaving us wanting more Juliet Nichols
did some things that no one in living
memory has done before her she refused
to clean and because her suit was sealed
correctly thanks to Walker getting
Supply to change out the heat tape she
not only survived the cleaning but
walked over the hill to leave her Silo
behind her world just got a lot bigger
and with Revelation comes a host of new
questions which are now situated on top
of a pile of other ones that are still
lingering which isn't a bad thing
necessarily I'm not going to get into
any specific book spoilers in this video
but I will say this before we get
started all mysteries in this series
lead back to one thing The Silo itself
this sets up a sequence of layered
reveals that keep going deeper and the
book series is very thorough in
providing answers nothing is guaranteed
but with the success of the first season
it seems likely that we will get to see
the complete adaptation of the story
which means you shouldn't have to worry
if you'll get answers or not one
question that we know the answer to Is
That season two is coming and they're
already filming it this is promising
since even though there's a lot of
effects work and post-production that
goes into a project like this the fact
that they're already filming means that
we shouldn't have to wait as long as we
do on some other Big Shows by far the
biggest question on everyone's Minds is
what will Jules find now that she's
walked away from The Silo of course
those rings and sensor towers are
exactly the same as what she just walked
away from indicating that there are more
silos nearby she does have a limited Air
Supply in that small backpack she's
wearing which if that is truly the only
air she has Narrows down her options one
question I've seen a lot after the
finale and one that I couldn't answer
without further investigation was why
you don't see Holston and Allison's body
when the camera zooms out the question
itself was confounding because I thought
the show did a good enough job of
revealing that they were dead so much so
that when I watched the finale I was
just looking at all those other circles
dotting the landscape but because so
many people brought this up in the
comments of my episode 10 video I went
back and looked and also had a hard time
seeing the bodies series author and
Creator Hugh Howie did a Reddit AMA
after the finale where he addressed this
saying that if the bodies weren't there
then it must have been the CGI people
missing a critical detail user Mr
notorious man responded to that with an
extreme close-up to show that the bodies
are in fact there and what jumped out
about that was the scale of things how
hard it was to locate Jules because of
how small she is going back to the wide
shot now I can see that there are some
light pixels for all three characters
which is enough for me to consider this
an answered question Holston and
Allison's bodies are still right where
they died just as the people inside see
them on the screen another question I've
seen a lot is how many silos are there
based on the closing shot there are at
least dozens which lines up with the
most popular idea from people who
haven't read the books which says that
the number 18 on Bernard's fob and on
the hard drive indicate that our Silo is
number 18. I think the more interesting
questions here are whether there's
people in all of them and if there are
are they all in the same program or
whatever you want to call it are they
all being controlled in this same way
and whether or not that's true what does
that mean why was this set up in the
first place and that leads into the next
obvious question of why does the outside
world look like that the people inside
The Silo grew up thinking that they were
the only people left alive from the
before times the official log line from
the show reflects that saying Silo is
the story of the last 10 000 people on
Earth their mild deep home protecting
them from the toxic and deadly World
outside knowing that there are other
silos makes that first part seem
unlikely so then do we need to question
whether or not they're on Earth I guess
that depends on what you think about
this destroyed cityscape that you see in
the background it does resemble what you
see here on Earth but I suppose you
could make the argument that if we went
to other planets we'd probably make the
same kinds of buildings but I guess at
the end of the day that's a question
more about why are they inside The Silo
who put them there more than it's about
what's going on with Jules at the end of
the season the person who might know
more about this is Bernard and that
leads to the next question what's behind
the door that he unlocked with the fob
slash switchblade key with the 18 on it
the fact that that lights up hints at it
being a signal which has to come from
somewhere because the lights weren't on
inside the room when he opened the door
it doesn't look like there was someone
inside calling him because the show has
blurred the lines and given judicial a
much larger role while adding the
surveillance room in the Janitor's
Closet I'm not exactly sure what's going
on in the server room itself it'll be
interesting to find out what he does
next one thing I've seen repeated after
the finale is that he rushed over there
to open the doors and disable the
display in jules's helmet I guess some
viewers came to the conclusion that he
disabled the augmented reality the green
background that she was seeing that
wasn't how I thought the scene was
supposed to read to me it was just a
reveal that Bernard knows more than
everyone else which is backed up by Sims
not knowing what he meant when he said
she knows and the way they cut the scene
after he opened the door is just a way
to make us wonder what he'll do now that
the cleaning didn't go as planned I take
Bernard at his word that he does what he
does because he believes that it's
necessary for the survival of the silo
it's the whole sacrifice of the few for
the life of thousands to come argument
why he believes that is the big mystery
that's wrapped up in all of that I think
this mostly applies to Sims as well only
he is in a completely different position
he knows a lot more than the average
citizen he has access to all those
detailed records about the relics but
the finale made it clear that he knows
less than Bernard that's why the idea of
him becoming his shadow is important
that will have to involve some sort of
initiation in order for him to be able
to take over for Bernard he has to know
the same things so I wonder how much he
knows at the moment but it's more in the
sense of how does he feel about that we
saw that conversation between him and
his wife where I thought that she hinted
that they had ulterior motives I don't
necessarily think these are dark motives
perhaps her history of being a Raider
and some of what she saw during that
period of time has had a lasting impact
on her I believe Sims does want to take
over he does want to become Bernard's
Shadow but I also wonder what she means
when she says they have one goal because
that doesn't seem like she just wanted
to get some power and maintain the
status quo and one other thing about
Bernard I wasn't entirely sure about the
look on his face when Juliet mentioned
the large metal door that George
discovered you could tell he was
surprised but I couldn't tell if that
was supposed to indicate that he was
surprised that she knew about it or if
he didn't know about it himself Hugh
Howie also addressed this in his AMA
saying that Bernard had no idea such a
thing existed this is interesting
because there was also that scene where
he was looking at the pieces of the hard
drive he destroyed which hints that he's
possibly now wondering about what else
he might not know to this point his
faith has seem somewhat unconditional so
if he's thinking about putting that hard
drive back together to investigate that
almost has to lead somewhere it's a
little hard to speculate on the metal
door itself after reading the book the
most popular idea I see out there is
that it's a door that connects the silos
together but if that's the case what's
up with the water and why doesn't
Bernard know about them these are both
good questions that I may or may not
know the answers to the other character
who I'm curious about is Billings I'm
really interested to know what kind of
deal they made after Sims outed him for
having the syndrome how do we get to a
place where both I.T and judicial are
willing to make an exception for him so
that he becomes the next Sheriff of
course we can see how they would want
him in a place where they could control
him but it seems like it will get out
that he has the syndrome that may not go
over well it may not be good for morale
and I guess what's even more interesting
than that is where is Billings at in his
head at the moment after he saw the book
and he burned it he seemed to be on a
different trajectory so it's hard to
tell how much he'll follow along with
what they want him to do and they might
be in a situation where they need a
strong Sheriff Jules walking away is
going to cause some kind of reaction
amongst the regular people Walker knows
they were using bad tape for a specific
reason and everyone in the down deep
basically knows that they sent Jules out
on trumped-up charges that she probably
didn't ask to go outside she did keep up
her end of the bargain she didn't stir
up any additional unrest on her way out
but how do the powers that be get
everyone to just go along with business
as usual after this event happened you
have to wonder how the down deep will
respond and what will happen to
characters like Walker and Pete Nichols
we saw Bernard vindictively sentenced
Lucas to the mines what will he do to
Walker or to the people in supply for
switching out to hey will he see people
who are close to her like her father as
threats I think that's most of the big
questions I've seen bouncing around what
will Jules do next what will Bernard do
next and how will the people left behind
in The Silo respond to this thing that
just happened who were the founders and
what were they trying to accomplish by
setting things up like this what would
they think about somebody walking away
after refusing to clean what does it
mean that there's so many other silos
and will we get to see the insides of
those do they send people out to clean
do they have flame Keepers like Gloria
trying to keep the memory of the before
times alive in them too and speaking of
Gloria was there anything to that idea
that they put something in the water to
make people forget two quick things
before I wrap this up I keep seeing the
theory that it isn't the air outside
that kills the cleaners but instead it's
the gas they spray on them before they
go out I can't comment on that either
way because I know the answer but I did
want to clarify what that's supposed to
be according to the book in regards to
holston's cleaning because the show
never really addressed it as he's
getting ready to go outside he's of the
belief that it's Argon gas that's used
to prep the airlock so that none of the
outside air gets in you see that there's
a fire after they go and that's supposed
to purify the chamber make of that what
you will but that's the way it's
explained when it's first introduced the
other thing is that if you were
following my coverage throughout the
season you might remember that I was
confused when they showed the cafeteria
screen glitch and showed the Green Hills
and blue skies landscape that was
similar to what the cleaners see inside
their helmets for a second knowing ahead
of time why the cleaners see it when
they go outside made it really hard to
understand why it would show up on the
big screen or how that would even happen
and according to his AMA Hugh how he
felt the same way in that he essentially
said that he thought it was just
included to give viewers something to
speculate about rather than it being a
big clue as to what was going on on it
didn't seem like he was a big fan of
this particular decision he does come up
with the reason for how you could make
it make sense which is funny because I
have one in my head Canon that's a
little bit different than his but the
bottom line is that you might not want
to invest too much time on trying to
make that detail fit in with any Grand
theories you're putting together and I
think that's a great place to leave
things season two can't get here fast
enough and if one thing stood out in my
conversation with Mr Howie it was that
he's really excited about what they've
been filming so far please like this
video If you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon